- I have a headache and
Google says it's brain cancer.
Do I have brain cancer?
(jazzy music)
- Hey mom, so I'm having
people over for the first time
this weekend, and I really need
your mac and cheese recipe.
- So what exactly are
stocks, how do I get them?
Do I need them?
- What should I make for the main dish?
- Who sings that Motown
song with the lyrics.
I don't know something
about heaven, charm.
There's an arm in there.
- Can I just get all your recipes?
Just, yeah, just send 'em all to me.
No, mom, not by mail,
just email them to me.
- Can I get your Netflix password?
- So how much is too
much to pay for braids?
- Hulu?
- So how exactly do you
fold a fitted sheet?
'Cause it's not looking quite right.
- HBO?
It won't cost you anything.
- How many times can
you wash a zip lock bag?
- Mommy, you need to talk to Sepha.
I know she's my sister, I love her,
but she is acting crazy.
- How often am I supposed to oil my scalp?
- When is cousin Shawn's birthday?
- Can you do my taxes for me?
- And what about Uncle Antonio?
Oh (beep), could you
apologize to him for me?
Yes, thank you and I
promise I will stop cussing.
- Do we have Native
American in our family?
Really?
What tribe?
- Hey, I just wanted to
tell you that I love you
and I miss you.
- And, I'm glad that I can
come to you for advice.
Yeah, I'm making sure I get my vitamins.
Yeah, uh, huh, I'm getting enough sleep.
Mom, I'm an adult.
(jazzy music)